good morning everybody I am Bob Wigley
chairman of UK Finance we as you
probably know are the collective voice
for the banking and finance sector and
I'm very much delighted to welcome you
all today to our headquarters
at UK Finance we Champion the role of
the financial services sector
and our priorities include supporting
consumers and businesses through this
very difficult current economic
environment
delivering economic growth the
transition to Net Zero
and fighting economic crime
these are crucial long-term issues for
the UK and therefore as we move towards
the next election
it will be fascinating to have a labor
party is thinking about the role of
business and The crucial issue of
generating growth for our economy and I
was delighted to read in your document
over the weekend
about your plans and what I am sure I
think all the Business Leaders here will
say is a potential move away from
looking at business as something to be
just taxed and regulated towards
business as a key government partner to
help create a real industrial strategy
and deliver government priorities whilst
addressing businesses needs to
facilitate growth so with that I very
much welcome Rachel Reeves Chateau
Chancellor of the exchequer
thank you
well thank you very much Bob and thank
you to UK Finance for hosting us here
this morning what a pleasure to be here
with all of you as Shadow Chancellor it
has been a huge privilege to speak to
Business Leaders and to entrepreneurs
all around our country to witness the
incredible Innovation the commitment the
creativity which drives the best of
British business
like Oxford nanopore whose pioneering
work on DNA and RNA sequencing is so
exciting
the work of Engineers at Rolls-Royce in
Derby in developing carbon neutral
Aviation and tread in my city of Leeds
which has launched the UK's first green
debit card
now mate no mistake
even in challenging times across whole
swathes of the UK economy Britain is a
world leader
a Pioneer in sectors from creative
Industries to Life Sciences
the second largest exporter of services
anywhere in the world including fintech
and green Finance
Great British successes with so much
more potential
but when I meet Business Leaders
as well as the determination to succeed
I also hear time and again
is a deep sense of frustration
frustration that for all the hard work
and creative Talent
but all the potential that exists in
this country
too much is squandered amidst the
political dysfunction and economic
instability
every successful business that I meet
has a clear business plan a sense of
purpose
we must ask we must ask
why isn't it the same for the British
government
why in place of that sense of clear
United purpose do we see short-term
thinking Division and all too often
chaos
where is the sense of purpose to bring
together the public and private sector
national and local leaders in a spirit
of partnership
now kids speech in Manchester last week
was important a key moment for the labor
party in setting out the ambition that
the next Labor government will show
an alternative to sticking plaster
politics
the commitment that we're making is this
that with Kia in number 10 Downing
Street and with me at the treasury
in the place of chaos of instability in
our policy making and in our politics we
will have a mission-led government
future facing and guided by clear and
ambitious priorities
those Ambitions must start with the
economy
because the Deep challenges we face
today are just one chapter in the longer
story of economic decline
of low growth
low productivity and low investment
that's not just the matter of lines on a
graph
it has deep implications
for our Public Services
for every family every business every
town and every city
and the potential of us as a country
now I started my career at the bank of
England
I was assigned to monitor the Japanese
economy during what was known as Japan's
lost decade
we now speak about Japan's lost decades
so I know something about what can
happen to an economy once the Envy of
the world
if it becomes trapped in a cycle of low
growth
lost confidence and weak demand
believing when I say I know that what we
are announcing in this mission
is this huge Challenge and the scale of
the talent the the challenge ahead is
immense but it's because we are
ambitious of Britain that we have to be
bold
our mission is to secure the highest
sustained growth in the G7
with good jobs and productivity in all
parts of the country making everyone
not just a few better off
based on a naive hope
but on a new approach
Guided by the understanding that wealth
doesn't just trickle down from the top
comes from the bottom up and the middle
out from the talents and efforts of
millions of working people and thousands
of businesses
the key is contribution
I think we want our country to fill its
potential then we can't just draw upon
the contribution of a few people
a few businesses or a few places it has
to be a collective National effort
this is no time to cling to old
orthodoxies
our peers and our competitors across
Europe and Asia from Australia to the
United States are rising to the
challenges of the future
rebuilding their economic resilience
pursuing active industrial and Regional
policies and leading in the race for the
industries of the future
because they understand
as our government seems not to but is in
a changing and an unstable world it is
no longer enough if it ever was for
government to Simply get out of the way
all of our Ambitions will hinge upon the
success of a thriving private sector and
dynamic markets
but if the countries are showing
sustained economic growth relies on an
active government
role
as a partner to business
now that is why over the past 18 months
we have set out Labor's green Prosperity
plan
a plan to decarbonize our economy to
deliver energy Independence to drive
down bills to create good jobs right
across our country and to give British
business the chance that they need to
compete
it is why we will Implement a modern
industrial strategy to enshrine that
Spirit of partnership
and it is why we will pursue the biggest
pushing out of power from Westminster to
unlock the potential found in every town
and every city across our country
that is what this mission is about
it's about building on and unlocking the
potential that I see everywhere that I
go
that is what Kia and I are here to set
out today
over the past few weeks we have worked
together closely to develop this plan
the first mission in Labor's plan for a
Greener fairer more Dynamic Britain
and over the years to come
we hope to have the chance to work
together with all of you
to deliver on these commitments in
government
so now let me hand over to the person
who's guiding Mission I know will shape
our country for the better Kia stama
thank you
foreign
thanks to all of you for coming here
this morning to launch Labor's mission
for the British economy and I have to
say it's just fantastic looking around
the rooms and see the faces of people I
would Now call colleagues that have
worked with us on this over the last two
years and I hope I say this to many
people in the room but you see your
fingerprints on some of what we're
saying the influencing the thinking of
Rachel and of me about the partnership
that we need to build and that is a
collective ambition it is genuine
partnership to secure the highest estate
growth in the G7
with good jobs
productivity growth in every part of the
country and growth which makes everyone
not just a few better off
now I won't be about the bush with an
audience like this you know that our
country has distinctive strengths our
universities our service exports
excellence in life sciences Finance Tech
and creative Industries
but you also know that these strengths
depend upon stability and standing
global standard
and that these two fundamentals things
we've always taken for granted in
Britain have undeniably taken a hit
now I know this isn't a partisan
audience
but we do need to be frank about the
path of decline the Tories have set us
up
and it's not it's not just the chaos of
the last 12 months
there's also the 12 years that went
before it the austerity which gnawed
away at our growth potential and placed
the mess made Let's be blunt in this
part of the city
onto the shoulders of working people
12 years where I trickle down and
trickle out growth strategies failed to
deliver a better future for them
12 years where other countries sped past
us in the race for the opportunities of
tomorrow
and that's what our growth mission is
about
the British people are falling behind
whilst our European neighbors get richer
in the east as well as in countries like
France and Germany
and I'm not comfortable about that
not comfortable with a trajectory that
will soon see Britain overtaken by
Poland
nor am I prepared to accept what the
consequences of this failure would mean
I don't want a Britain where young
people in our great towns and cities are
left with no option but to get out
a brain drain
not just to London or Edinburgh but to
Leon Munich and Warsaw
that's not the future our country
deserves
but nobody owes us a future either we've
got to get it back ourselves claw back
that sense of stability and standing
because when the big questions that Echo
around rooms like this are raised
where does our money go where do our
jobs go where does our investment in a
better future go
I want the answer that comes back to be
a resounding why not Britain
and that's why I went to Davos with
Rachel last year
and we've met thousands of Business
Leaders over the last year or two CEOs
all over the country as I said many of
you are here today many of you would be
talking to for a considerable period of
time and with lessons we've heard loud
and clear about the need for certainty
that basic truth chaos has a cost
that investors need a clear framework
with policies that are always fully
costed
fiscal rules sound and followed
rigorously
constraints accept it
institutions respected and not bypass a
rock of economic stability our entire
Mission fruit growth is built on that
and don't doubt it for a second
but
honestly
isn't this the least we should expect
I think so
Britain needs certainty yes
but also change
this is my real ambition the goal that
fires my imagination a new model for
economic growth
growth from the Grassroots
where wealth is created Everywhere by
everyone for everyone
where we take off the blinkers to the
potential of an active government that
sets the direction
and where we come together in a
partnership raise our Collective sites
beyond the day-to-day
deliver the long-term Solutions our
country needs
so here in this document
the mission
secure the highest sustained growth in
the G7
a measurable goal
an invitation for the British people to
judge us on whether they feel better off
after five years of a labor government
but also the building blocks of a clear
strategy the first steps of a credible
long-term plan a plan which represents
the determination of my party to create
more wealth lead Britain out of its
low-wage high tax doomly could have
confidence
outstanding and our future back
so five shifts in Britain's growth model
from chaos to certainty from hoarding
potential to unlocking power in every
Community from lagging to Leading on
science technology green growth and the
opportunities of tomorrow
a labor market that moves from too many
insecure jobs to good jobs for all
and to Britain that is resilient to
Global shocks and open to global trade
in each of these five areas we have
three clear commitments 15 Steps on the
path to National renewal
important steps like our modern
industrial strategy we're just talking
about that this morning but we'll get
everyone around the table and remove the
barriers to investment that partnership
bringing business into government with
us
a green Prosperity plan that will
provide a catalytic investment needed to
become a clean energy superpower
a more powerful British Business Bank
that will support startups to grow and
scale
more flexible skills training
apprentices and short courses which can
train coders of programmers in weeks
and a fixed brexit deal
a reset relationship with the EU
for the whole of the country not just
Northern Ireland
all this and more is in this document
and on growth
it's the only show in town
but I also want to go straight with you
and with the British people
yes our Ambitions are ambitious
the highest sustained growth in the G7
that should be a sharp intake of breath
for anyone in this room and those that
we've been discussing this with
but there's a humility that comes with
this ambition
it's important part of what we have to
say we can't do this alone
change comes from all of us
growth comes from all of us
mission-driven government is about much
more than cherry picking the numbers on
a spreadsheet and saying job done
it's about national pride a national
renewal
not State control or pure free markets
but a genuine partnership sleeves rolled
up working for the national interests
the how is as important as the what
partnership is an economic imperative
so today I ask you to join me the
now is the time to be part of something
bigger a partnership between business
unions Civil Society communities
between all our four nations
and most radically of all between
politicians and people
a national mission that changes not just
what we do on growth
but how we do it
Because unless we unlock the potential
of every region and every nation we will
never fix our economy and that is my
fundamental belief
a belief that grounds my offer of
partnership in a driving purpose
that's what we've got to unite our
country around
and look I don't want to mess people
around either
I want everyone on board
but we do have to accept the need for a
new model
I'm serious we've got to change how the
country grows and who it grows for
got to find the courage to take on
vested interests
that lack of will is part of what's
holding Britain back
I met the people running the National
Grid recently you pleased to hear this
and they said to me if we want to get
anywhere near our goals on that zero we
need to build more infrastructure in the
next seven years than we've done in the
last 30.
this is a problem
nothing reeks more of decline than the
idea Britain can no longer do big things
that benefit working people
and would never accept that
so
if you think it's not government's role
to shape markets that we're only here to
serve them
for the labor market which locks in low
pay and productivity is something Beyond
reform
or that the planning system should favor
the already wealthy not the new houses
wind farms and Laboratories we need to
create more wealth
and that's not going to work for us
that's not going to work for growth
we won't deliver what our country needs
now you'll appreciate we'll put a lot of
work into this and we know growth is the
answer
every one of our national missions
depends on it
Safe Streets an NHS fit for the future
tearing down the barriers to opportunity
a clean energy superpower all of these
are good for growth
but all of them require growth the
lifeblood of a dynamic economy and a
strong Society
its higher wages stronger communities
more vibrant High streets public
services that lift you up less poverty
more opportunity warmer homes healthier
food holidays meals out more cash in
your pocket
an end to the suffocating cost of living
crisis
and the only chance we have to regain
that standing to get our future back and
give that answer
why not Britain thank you very much
we've got some questions from the media
now so
um Antonello I think is first yes stop
you
thank you very much
um a question of migration you have just
talked about the young living in the
country but we also know that this
country desperately needs workers mostly
low-skilled ones and there were more
than one million jobs of vacancies and
the NHS itself needs more than one 100
000 new workers but you previously said
that UK businesses must win off cheap
labor and that the low pay model for
growth is no longer working so how can
you find a compromise how can you fix
this issue of job vacancies and are you
ready to relax the rules on migration
into this situation persists and a
persists sorry and secondly very quickly
it's a big
paragraph if you become PM what would be
your first concrete act to have a better
relationship with the EU as you promised
thank you
um thank you very much look on this
question you guys it's obviously a huge
question it came up at the CPI
conference that I did in the tail end of
last year in October I think and also at
the nfu conference that I did last week
and I was clear to both of those
audiences
um that we recognize the short-term
problem and we're not going to be
anti-business or anti-growth or
anti-farming about this and allow
short-term problems to create long-term
problems
but we do have to get ourselves off the
idea that migration is the answer to all
of our problems we've had a skills
um problem in this country for decades
before brexit I was the shadow
immigration Minister and I went around
the country talking to businesses about
and ask them a simple question what's
the single biggest impediment to your
growth in the next five years to which
the answer was skills we don't have the
skills we need where we need them so
we've got to fix that
um and you know we've also got and
Jonathan Ashworth has been doing a huge
amount of work on this we've got many
people who were in the labor market two
or three years ago who aren't in the
labor market now we need to have a
long-term plan so the answer is in the
short term of course we'll work with
businesses to ensure that they've got
the skills that they need but we've got
to accept that that is exactly what
we've been talking about it's a sticking
plaster because the long-term solution
is actually about the skills about the
investment and about making sure that we
get the workforce we've got here in the
UK back into work on
um brexit um just I strongly believe
that
the single most important thing for an
incoming labor government is to restore
trust and credibility in the process
we've been bedeviled in recent years by
a lack of trust we'll see where today
gets us with the protocol but certainly
in all my dealings and conversations
it's a basic lack of trust that's been
the single biggest impediment thank you
very much I think we're going to go to
Stefan at Politico Stefan here uh Stefan
Bosch at Politico firstly many
businesses have been really concerned
about Joe Biden inflation reduction Act
and the effect that we'll have on
business in the UK and Europe are you
firstly are you willing to
um respond to that in a similar way the
EU has and you know baking it into your
green subsidies plan you've already
announced and then secondly on the
Newland protocol uh negotiations how
would you have handled them differently
what would have your plan been to solve
this issue
um good Stefan just on
inflation reduction pack firstly this is
obviously a big big issue and when
Rachel and I were in Davos it was
discussed up hill and downdale including
the EU response and
um my sadness at Davos was the fact that
the UK wasn't part of that discussion we
weren't at the table we'd been it was
felt that the UK somehow drifted off the
international stage and so the first
thing we would do is and this was our
statement of intent when we were in
Davos is we're going to reverse that
we're going to be on the stage and be
part of those discussions on the
specifics our green Prosperity plan is
already a plan to address some of the
issues that the IRAs addressing in
America and therefore we will build on
those plans in terms of the protocol my
long-held belief having talked to
businesses in particularly Northern
Ireland but also in Dublin
is that there are practical steps
forward in relation to the protocol that
would make the protocol work a lot
better that could have been taken 18
months two years ago but we've been
stuck in an impasse
um I do think this is an opportunity I
think uh probably everybody in this room
now
um recognizes that the EU and the UK are
probably in agreement or very near to
agreement at this stage the question
will be whether the Prime Minister has
got the strength to sell it to his back
benches or not and I think many people
will be frustrated that this is the loop
we've been stuck in for a very very uh
long time that's not something we'd have
with the labor government because we
don't have those divisions in our party
on this issue thank you Stefan Ben from
the mirror Ben thank you Ben glass and
the Daily Mirror and you talked about
increasing wages in your speech what do
you think the level of the minimum wage
should be and would a labor government
support a real living wage as opposed to
the National living wage yeah Ben thank
you for raising that because
um we do want wages to want living
standards to go up
um I want
um this to be determined independently
by a process that puts living standards
at the heart of this
um so that we can change the whole
approach but Ben I would also say that
um you know incoming labor governments
of course want High wages High living
standards uh of course we do but what
we're answering is the question of how
you're going to do that then
um and you're not really going to get
Higher Living living standards higher
wages unless you have a proper
strategical growth a long-term strategy
for growth
um and that's why we've seen you know
the failure of growth over the last 13
years trying to put all politics aside
in the last 13 years we haven't had
growth where we need it it's been far
too slow for a combined number of
reasons we've got to turn that around
and that's why the strategy for growth
is also the strategy for higher wages
and higher living standards and it's and
I think it's clear from what I said on
Thursday from what Rachel said and what
I've said this morning
the model for growth that we are
absolutely focused on is a model that
increases living standards everywhere
there is a model for growth which says
you could put even more into London and
Southeast and I've got nothing against
London the southeast to do a lot of you
know heavy carrying just at the moment
but I don't want a model for Britain
that says this is where you create the
wealth and then we sort of basically
redistribute it through various
mechanisms the rest of the country I
want that productivity those good jobs
everywhere across the country and I
don't just mean to the next city either
by the way Lisa will be looking at me on
this checking out I'm absolutely focused
on it but it's got to be something it
can't be just London and Manchester and
Leeds it's got to be everywhere all the
towns around as well thank you Ben uh
then I'll go to Alita from the guardian
by the current tax burden so do you hope
to be able to reduce personal taxes
after the election if you win well look
I I you know I want to create an economy
where growth is the answer we give
before tax or spend and let me just
spell that out
if the growth in the last 13 years
had been at the same rate as growth on
the last Labor government we would have
40 billion pounds more to spend on our
public services without raising a penny
in tax and that's why my first answer on
tax is always growth because if you're
just taxing a diminishing return then
you're not really going to get anywhere
so
um yes we want to make sure you know we
want to make sure that the tax burden on
working people is as low as it possibly
can be we know how hard the cost of
living crisis hitting people and that
need for money in your pocket at the end
of the month but the answer on tax the
answer on spend has to start with growth
and that figure of 40 billion pounds
without raising a penny more in tax if
you have the same growth last Labor
government really makes its own case uh
Eleanor from inews
hello Hi Kia um there's been a lot of
talk recently about the economic impacts
of brexit and how that's damaging the
economy how would a labor government
ensure that brexit could be utilized
properly to grow
yeah thank you Eleanor the first thing
I'd say is
I think we we are
fooling ourselves if we think that the
only problem with growth
is brexit because if you look at those
13 years the last 13 years on the growth
we haven't had growth you know
meaningful growth uh in any of those 13
years so the problem we've had on growth
and skills and investment predated
brexit and therefore to Simply say the
problem is brexit and the answer is
brexit I think fails to deal with the
underlying issues which are so important
about investment and stability
and whenever I talk to CEOs
businesses including people in this room
about
the single biggest driver of investment
it is stability the the profound message
from places like Davos was look
we do have the potential to invest but
all the time you're going through three
prime ministers four chancellors of all
budgets in 12 months that may be
politically quite amusing but it is not
creating the circumstances for
investment in the UK just at the moment
so if we're going to overcome this we
have to create those conditions of
stability on brexit itself I do think
there are improvements that we can make
to the deal that's why we will reset the
relationship and I've set them out and
it obviously starts with the protocol
but it's got to go Way Beyond the
protocol an absolute clarity about the
high standards that we want the
collaboration we want when it comes to
science and research I think there's
much more we can do in the field of
security particularly after the 12
months of the awful conflict in Ukraine
so I do think there are real
um changes to the brexit deal to improve
it that would be one part of a plan for
growth but it can't be the whole plan
for growth otherwise I think we will
risk not dealing with the fundamental
issues that underpin
um the problem we've had with growth for
a very long time I've got Jack from the
Sun
chat thank you secure
um you've said that you would back any
brexit deal negotiated by the Prime
Minister as a details man how can you
back a deal but you haven't even seen
and would you like Northern Ireland to
be inside or outside the remit of the
European court of justice uh Jack look
thank you for that I've obviously
um as you probably know I worked in
Northern Ireland for five years so I
know Northern Ireland very very well
spent a lot of time there recently
talking through what the issues are with
the protocol and that led particularly
with businesses there's a very good
business group in Belfast who have put
together a 14-point plan of what they
need changed so you know yes we haven't
seen the deal yet but I'm completely
across what the issues are and what the
Practical Solutions are everybody in the
room probably knows what are the issues
that are outstanding and what are the
likely resolutions
um to those and frankly
um any step in those directions is going
to be an improvement on what we've got
which is why I say with confidence
expect to be able to back the deal with
there is one this afternoon or whenever
we might see it it's not going to be a
surprise it's not going to be out of the
blue we've been working on these
problems for a very very long time and
know what some of the solutions are look
it is almost inevitable that the ECG
will have to play some part in this I
think the Prime Minister recognizes that
the government recognizes that but we've
just we've got to make progress I think
you know we owe it to the people of
Northern Ireland to get on and fix this
they're desperate to have this um fixed
they deserve to have it fixed and we
need to fix it for the whole of the um
UK thank you Jack and then I've got Theo
from LBC from LBC in terms of looking at
immigration and the immigration
shortages to this country labor
shortages in the market here do you see
the solution to that as granting access
to young young people workers in the
European Union free access to the you to
Great Britain or do you see that sitting
within a Visa scheme a special visa for
uh for for labor on the agriculture in
the health sector how do you how do you
envisage that if you become Prime
Minister uh thank you for it it's more
likely to be of a Visa scheme
um but I go back to what I said at the
beginning which is
um we we will not be anti-business we
will not allow short-term problems to
gum up the system in a way which further
undermines our economy but we are
looking beyond that uh we want to fix
the fundamentals
um and I'm still struck by how many
children leave school without the skills
they're actually going to need for the
jobs they're likely to be doing the
life's they're likely to be leading
still struck by the fact that many many
businesses still don't have the skills
that they need in the places that they
need them we've got to fix that now I
know this is a big problem we've had
this problem for 10 years or more but I
don't what I don't want to do is
somebody say well look let's just have
more visas out here full immediate
problem but not really fix the
fundamentals because
um you know in a sense that goes to the
heart of what is a mission-led
government I know the people say well
it's not very retail well true but
um you know if you want to fix your
economy in such a way but actually help
people pay their bills at the end of the
day raises their living status you've
got to do the fundamentals and
this this phrase sticking plaster
politics is it such an important phrase
to make up totally frustrated
by governments that just get by that
wait until we're at crisis point then
put a sticky plaster on then just wait
until the next problem and then another
slipping class we'd be doing that for 13
years and that's why we're in the
problems where we're in such a deep hole
I'm absolutely determined that we're
going to fix that I want people at the
end of a five-year labor government to
genuinely feel better off to have their
living standards let's have public
services but actually serve them in
their community that won't work if we
just do sticky plaster politics it will
only work if we are honest enough to say
these are the fundamentals these are the
five things that we must fix that will
be absolutely focused on as labor
government and where you will see
material change in five years for labor
government thank you all very much and
we'll see you in the round table in due
course thank you
thank you